Mình mừng tảm, sau sấu vòng lọc áo của bộ dữ của đào tạo,
có trường lần nưa thông bố điểm trung tuyển.
Chuyên đào công nghệ thung tiên đào PUSA thành phố Chím Minh có điểm chuẩn
từ 25,5 đến 30,5 điểm sau khuy đổi.
Trong đó, mức 30,8 người ở ngành trí tuyên tạo,
là lần đầu sốt hiện trong lịch sử của trường.
Nèo bấy khoa hành nội lấy từ 25,5 điểm,
học hiện ngăn hàng từ 25,5 điểm, sau phải sống y mô điểm.
Đi học hiện tệ cua sân từ 25,5,5 điểm,
thì hình hành tham về tảm từ 20,5 điểm.
học hiện hậu cần lấy hâm lắm về sống lắm đến 20,5 điểm.
Chuyên đào mấy khoa đào PUSA thành PUSH y mình lấy từ 50,5 điểm,
tảm lắm về tảm điểm trên tham một chăm.
Mọi gia đại học đại nè, lấy 50,5 điểm, 2,5 điểm, theo điểm thì tung nghiệp.
Đại học việt nhất từ 20,5 điểm, học viện phủ nước Việt Nam từ 20,5 điểm,
thì sống phẩy một điểm.
Thì sinh lâu ý điểm trần dự cái trường không hoàn toàn tương đường,
giòn mỗi trường có phương thức quy đổi dân.
Bảnh lắm đến tí sinh đăng ký sế tuyền đại học.
Tí sinh chung tuyển phải sáng nhận nhập học trên hiện thống của bộ giữ của đào tạo.
Trong người mại giờ ngày 2,5 tảm tảm.